In France, seven people were arrested in the search for two main suspects...
...in Wednesday's shooting spree that left 12 dead...
...at the Paris offices of the Charlie Hebdo satirical magazine.
Thousands rally around the world and hold banners saying "Je Suis Charlie", I am Charlie,...
...in solidarity with the slain journalists in France.
In Sri Lanka, voters head to the polls to decide the country's next president.
Metropolitan areas across the Middle East struggle to keep up with the snow storm...
...as Syrian refugees face harsh conditions.
And finally from Montenegro, a fan attacks a player and starts a brawl...
...between players and the fan at a Eurocup tournament basketball game.